spin out on the LA greetings of peace I
said I'm alaikum Justin how are you all
right are you actually not too long ago
a few years ago you actually accepted
Islam yes say about two years ago to
Masada why what made you make that
decision this growing up in a
non-religious home a lot of things I
have your question likewise like life
itself you know when you got the adults
and droughts and uh no you you want to
look for something to bring you up and
why not look for the answer most high
Allah so religion cut my no to find
answers and will let me to become Muslim
so what were you doing before Islam
where were you what were you involved in
you have to go into the details I mean
that did you feel just spiritually empty
did you how did you feel what was the
feeling that you felt before as compared
to now basically how you said it
spiritually empty a lack of guidance
that's what is long has done for me so
far has gotten me the right way the
makes your troubles come easier makes
answers come easier in the it does i've
lived to energy you know let's just you
know basically outside alysha energy to
a higher level where you feel more
confident and that's me so Justin when
you see yourself now and how long has it
been since you accept this it's been two
years uh so you're pretty much like a
baby now so everything is new for you
when you have certain individuals and
many people have many prejudices towards
Islam because it's the utter feel it's
the other they don't know it they don't
understand it but usually what I tell
people when you do get to know it if you
remove these prejudices you'll see that
this is something that connects with the
heart it's something that it's from the
Creator it makes sense just give it the
time of day you gave it a time of day
that's why you're here but when someone
throws at you oh and has this happened
like oh you say I'm Muslim over to your
radical now you're now you're one of
them you're a terrorist what do you say
as long as pure so when they come out
with stuff like that you know the the
basis of islam teaches you first of all
patients so I have many many people
combine with them uh with them slanders
and stuff like that and I'll just ask
them to open the book read it in your
finances yourself about how you look how
they view it terrorists selfoss believe
in the book speaks were at all so when
you start to open a book and read it I
feel like just open the book itself as
you begin reading you get a source of
energy coming to you know it speaks
truth right away from the beginning to
end so that's why what's up in the book
and self-educate yeah this is really
important because there are even some
Muslims you know they'll come into Islam
and they'll be really ecstatic and happy
but they're not seeking knowledge and
then they do something opposite of Islam
they go and misrepresent Islam because
Islam says have patience and now they're
on the street corner is getting the fist
fights because somebody says something
derogatory about Islam with Islam
doesn't teach that actually the crown
Allah God Almighty saying how to deal
with the ignorant people by saying words
of peace and just excusing yourself and
you said patience this is this is this
is this is keya yeah you know it teaches
you to the mind control you know evil is
easy to manipulate so without patience
you know you right away jump into
assuming to judging to all these long
ways of going about life so will
patience and you know that's what islam
teaches and it makes everything come to
you slower and you understand a lot more
and that makes life itself more
understanding a of purpose purpose many
people they when asked this question
they get like the deer in the headlights
that stump feeling you know they don't
think about it some people who do they
make their own purpose and say okay I'm
here to do some charity I have a family
when the
championships make this Grammy hit
number one whatever the case right this
is all you know something that's can be
a means but the ultimate purpose we know
what it is and how have you found that
Islam has answered this question is
crucial question and many people they're
not reflecting about some people they've
concocted their own way but Islam we
know is from the Creator how has it
filled this void and answered this
crucial question about the purpose of
life why we are here is it pretty clear
now to you as opposed to before Islam
yeah definitely I mean we all think
these other things as a purpose of
living like to like you said win a
championship and everything like that
but that's that's you know less than a
short period of time you know God is
forever so we gotta answer like what's
our purpose being here you know we're
not here forever so that's I mean is it
shows you clearly our purposes submit to
Allah you know so I mean Islam is
definitely a clear that you know for me
what's the purpose in life is you know
duta when you start to read inside the
religion or I mean this when you're not
religious and you question yourself once
again Islam we open the book it shows
your guidance and the guidance helps you
figure out a purpose so before are not
yet Muslims for our brothers in humanity
maybe sometimes you hear you know two
Caucasian white guys and see a law and
then you just like it spooked out I mean
that's just if somebody was from the
Latinos they would say deals God in
English in the language that Jesus spoke
he didn't speak English she spoke
Aramaic and he called on God by the name
Allah ha and we're saying Allah this is
the Creator who has no beginning no end
he has no children he's not like anybody
he is indeed the one who created
creation Allah and you have your coming
you know taking those baby steps you're
coming along tell us something else that
you'd like to share with the you know
audience that can kind of motivate
people to really do what you did in two
take life serious you know it's not
about playing basketball football
partying you know and just forgetting
about your purpose what what what are
the things you can you can say her and
to try to motivate people to really take
life serious and really to seek out
what's the purpose of my life something
I will get back as a I would say is to
sit down I invite with yourself evaluate
everything going around you know when
you got set ups and downs there's
nothing this world that can really
prepare you for how this works won't go
but God seeking god that's the best way
to prepare yourself so I say if you
really you know that if you really have
doubt first is a evaluate yourself and
then open the book open the book it
that's that's is it's the key to a lot
you never stop learning God you never
stop learning so it's the one so if you
want and like to live for purposes
search for it so open so I'll religion
read all you know in self educating and
you will see we open that book the Quran
you know right away you start finding
answers because many people come into
Islam they've they read the Bible
they've looked into Buddhism to
Confucianism to all the world religions
I did the same thing I wanted to make
sure if i'ma practice Islam is it can't
be a ridge and organized by man or men
it has to be from the Creator I'll open
up a world religions book and you can
see from the face from this doesn't make
sense this doesn't connect with the
heart man is this is something that just
way out there but like you said this la
makes sense it makes sense worship the
Creator not to creation it's laid out
how we need to live our lives from A to
Z and Justin I really enjoy talking to
people who have made this very important
decision tell me that do you feel what
you've done now and compared to how you
were living before how do you feel
you're becoming a better human being do
you feel that you've grown spiritually
we're with your connection with God
definitely you know before I become
Muslim you do you I think everybody even
people whose disbelievers you always
feel emptiness so how about chain is
definitely changing as a better person
uh I always keep my patience cuz life
you know people don't kill that enough
you know they rush it and everything so
it definitely changed me into a better
person humble me what made me more wiser
even at my young age you know ages are
some number Wyatt wisdom and being
humble you knows hmm it's a one and
that's what that's what is llamas done
for me is from Dan you know being
impatient one in unnecessary once and
everything so that's what it's done for
me it made me be patient and be more
humbled by life and number of key things
going and going and going into life you
know when you're trying to find yourself
so one key thing before we end another
point I just want to focus it was there
a point in time that's you because I
always tell people look if you want to
know the truth has got to be simple to
understand and easy to find and where
does it start within yourself reflecting
thinking and that contemplating and then
removing those desires that you have
inside you and say okay this is not the
most important thing I should be doing
in life right drinking party and play
and hold out that's not going to get me
anywhere and then doing some real simple
did you do this many people they find
that after they have asked the Creator
the reality the one who created creation
guided me have you did something did you
do was there point that you remember
that you asked the crater alone to guide
me to show you the way strength and
guidance is key you that stuff from
Alana you know he will eventually answer
you so neither definitely uh were you
asking is there time when you were like
you were seeking to know and you were
saying God whoever you are guiding me to
the truth actually that's that's what
led me into become a Muslim I was asking
for seeking guidance no other trouble
going into life you know uh unanswered
things why is this going wrong why is
I'm not why I'm not getting blessed this
way or
whatever that's the question I asked us
for guidance you know no the Most High
God needs a truth and when you want
something that's one of the Hitchin when
I wanted it I feel like that's how God
led me to Islam so guidance is
definitely about two years because when
I ask for guidance and then I mean
that's simple that is something that's
not a logical way if someone was asking
you to pray to mar 22 aliens and and and
unidentified creatures or some some
little statue or anything in creation
that your instinct would reject this but
when you're being told to try something
that's not going to bring you any harm
but a whole world of goodness can open
that you call upon the Most High if
there's a picture of you in your mind of
them no that's not God God is the one
who created creation but he's not a part
of creation he's the one that can only
guide you to the truth but you have to
ask the owner of truth who is the one
able to give you that peace and direct
you to purpose and that's where it
starts right there and then he will
facilitate away try it right now he have
nothing to lose ask the most high for
guidance and guide me why am I here why
I'm in this world to just party and play
then you die and it's finished do what
Justin did do it those sincere
individuals who wanna know the truth ask
the owner of true of God Almighty don't
have to say his name say the one who
created me guide me guide me guide me
we'll see you next time until then peace
be with you Islamic